what we've been hearing from
all the public health officials
uh at this point now that they're
finally beginning to
grant that
that the randomized control trials were
too short that they were indeed shorter
even than they were supposed to be
uh that the efficaciousness
uh that was supposedly demonstrated in
them was not quite exactly and in many
ways not at all what it was that we were
told it was um but specifically with
regard to safety increasingly the tune
has changed right the tune is no longer
of course
um of course we did everything that we
always do
because it's become totally clear that
they didn't um
as so uh
in octage october of 2021 norman deutsch
published this excellent piece and
tablet at like a three or four part i
don't remember what um called
needlepoints
which explores what he calls vaccine
hesitancy that's the term that is used i
don't i don't like it but um and it's
really it's really extraordinary and uh
he also read it aloud on jordan
peterson's podcast for those who would
prefer to to read it um but here in
and a pdf of all of the pieces together
is available so here's a 38-page
document that is available if you go to
tablet i'll link there but here's just a
pdf
of it um
three two thirds of the way through or
half the way through
deutsche writes still it was obvious as
early as the fall this would have been
sorry i think this is going to be fall
of 2020.
still it was obvious as early as the
fall that some testing steps would be
skipped
we'll have less safety testing than we
typically would have gates noted we just
don't have the time
and um
you know it
that's that's bill gates who said that
he was certainly not the only one of the
people pushing the one solution for the
massive problem that we are all sharing
uh but it's uh so you know his words are
not unique in this regard but
they are
telling because this is a rhetorical
trick that is becoming the thing that is
used against us
of you know first first there's the
lying the obfuscation you know of course
we did everything according to protocol
of course these are totally safe of
course we know
and then if and only if enough people in
the public going like you know what you
couldn't possibly have here's how i know
and they are forced to reveal that
actually there were safety
steps skipped
or
or fudged or whatever it is
then the story we get is
well of course we did
a you know no acknowledgement that they
had just lied to you of course we did of
course we skipped some safety but it's
necessary because this is an emergency
and so this is just like
freaking trudeau invoking the
emergencies act against a bunch of
people who are standing up for their
freedoms right
and this is this is this is like almost
all of the rhetoric that we get back
when we resist now and so before you
i'm going to step out outside of this
particular conversation for a moment to
go to something that seems completely
other
um
but it uses the same it uses exactly the
same rhetorical trick
and
this is on an issue um about which
um
you know we we actually do feel that
there is something that needs to be done
and reasonable people do disagree this
is going to be about climate change
reasonable people do disagree and this
is not about you have to accept the
science as if the science is a thing
but
we are so often told
that because climate change is the
emergency just like the code pandemic is
the emergency
it is okay if we skip certain things
like burden of proof like scientific
evidence and go forward with the one
solution that's been proposed this is
anti-scientific it's anti-democratic
it's pro-tyranny it's all you know all
of the bad things and here's just a
particular example
so we have um
here's an article zach if you just show
my screen briefly and then i'll pull my
screen back
uh this is um
science science news so uh about about
some work that's being done it's not
published it's not some research that's
being published in science but about
work being done by a biotech firm the
headline is and this is from the 23rd of
february 2022 to fight climate change a
biotech firm has genetically engineered
a very peppy poplar
okay
and it's you know it's it's a
in the voice that we have now come to
expect from
science journalism even at one of the
two premier science journals in the
world that's very much ra ra this is
this is this is not journalism this is
advocacy one
and uh if i may have my screen back zach
so that i can just see what i wanted to
read what quotes i wanted to read here
um
we have in the article
um
the the transgenic trees are growing
fast and the idea is that faster growth
means faster take-up of carbon dioxide
and therefore that's going to slow down
climate change that's the that's the
basic argument
um quote the firm's genetically enhanced
poplars grew more than 1.5 times faster
than unmodified ones in lab trials
uh and
there's a lot to say about what's wrong
with this research and and and we can go
there
but we have a quote from a forest
geneticist at oregon state university
who uh yes does in fact have a financial
stake in this outcome being what he
hopes it is so um there isn't even the
pretense that there's not uh financial
incentives here quote from the article
strauss for one believes the urgency of
addressing the climate crisis outweighs
potential risks associated with
transgenic trees we don't have the
luxury he says to wait for 30 years and
make sure nothing can possibly go wrong
oh really
transgenic trees
no they've they've generated uh
what look i mean they sound like a bunch
of dumb shits and so probably they
didn't do the work right and that's
probably what will protect us from their
madness but it sounds to me like what
they tried to do was create a really
impressive invasive species as if we
don't have a tragic invasive species
problem on virtually every continent
right and i mean
you know they bemoan in this article
how there are rules in place that
prevent if you're going to be um
be used as a sustainable forest project
you can't uh product rather you can't be
genetically modified it's like okay has
is anyone in this biotech firm noticed
what actually
naturally occurring fast-growing trees
true so let's take alder let's take
zakropia let's take a chroma balsa right
like just to name three of the world's
most known and widespread fast-growing
trees what is true of all of them they
grow fast they die young right they fall
over
very quickly they're light because they
are more air than structure because they
grew fast because that's what they do
yeah there are trade-offs that can't be
avoided yes or or let's take uh
eucalyptus right which is absolutely
devastating uh don't think it's
particularly fast growing well it's
particularly invasive and to the extent
that they've done their work at all well
to the extent that they are um
correct in at least arguing that this
would capture a bunch of carbon out of
the atmosphere then surely what they are
saying is that these are dense trees
right they have to be dense in order for
that to work right if they are you know
like secropia mostly hollow so just
secropia is actually the one that i
mentioned that may not be familiar to
people it's just it's it's uh it is the
uh
first
yeah the primary successional species um
in uh in lowland tropical and lowland
near tropical forest along with along
with balsa although people will know
that balsa wood you know basically
doesn't have as many molecules right you
can like you can take super light you
get you know you can get the like mini
dimensional lumber in terms of boss of
wood to build stuff and you know unless
it's unless it's like
a half by half inch like you can just
squish it right it's because it's that
soft wood because fast growing means
soft wood right in general let's say
that they've got you know the equivalent
of eucalyptus which is a very dense
hard wood right but nonetheless they're
talking again i don't think eucalyptus
is fast growing but
um eucalyptus has a different fast to
capture
habitat
right but i mean it's got it's got a
number of different tricks up its sleeve
yep right it's you know it it withstands
fire for instance yes it means it starts
starts fire but yeah um
but anyway look the point the point is
and i and we're going to have to work
our way back here but one of the
sort of themes of what we're getting at
which is actually going to link a bunch
of different things together
including
this will sound wrong but even the
appalling thing that has now taken place
in ukraine
is that in effect
we have a system in which everybody
who's supposed to be telling us what we
need to know has been
transmuted by
our economic system into a [ __ ]
salesman which is to say a liar right
and sometimes they do this by lying to
themselves i mean what salesman right is
going to invest in the precautionary
principle in which they're telling you
all of the reasons that actually you
shouldn't be listening to them because
the danger that they've missed something
is so great right or
a deep investigation of the trade-offs
where that salesman is now going to tell
you all the downsides of the cool thing
that they just tried to convince you
that you need to do and in fact what
they do instead
is they hijack your amygdala or whatever
it is and they utilize your fear to get
you to stop thinking
right and that is what they have done in
all of these cases they've said we don't
have time the emergency is too great and
therefore you're going to have to let us
get you out of this dangerous situation
that you will otherwise suffer from yeah
and it's it's monstrous it's like
amygdala spinal tap
this one goes to 11 and we're going to
keep it at 11 on you for as long as we
can and we're going to make sure that
you buy our stuff right that you buy our
stuff and the fact is this is sort of
how you and i ended up in the crazy
position that we're now in right because
the fact is you can actually check their
claims and you can't check them like no
that's wrong but you can check them like
actually that doesn't add up what you
just told me has a flaw in it somewhere
and it's either here or it's there and
here's how you know the company is
called living carbon and we are told in
this piece that's published in the news
branch of science magazine the journal
living carbon is also trying to engineer
trees to take up heavy metals from
degraded soils
company leaders hope those metals could
give the wood anti-fungal properties
that will reduce its decomposition rate
enabling it to store carbon longer
that actually makes sense to me it's not
a complete analysis
they're trying to reduce decomp in the
trees they have to
they have to because what they're what
they're arguing and frankly i don't
believe them because they are obviously
victims of this thing that has replaced
science with sales right right but what
they're trying to do what they want to
say is look
the way to reduce global warming in so
much in so far as global warming is the
result of too much of the ratio of
carbon in our atmosphere having gotten
too high right what they need to do
is pull that carbon out of the
atmosphere
in some way and that's worthless if it
gets pulled out and then returned on the
decomposition so basically the point is
but then but then
they're acknowledging that they have no
intention of these species being part of
any ecosystem ever
because if they are actually trying to
produce
trees
that grow fast presumably die young and
then lie there forever
not returning their nutrients to the
earth into the nitrogen cycle and you
know everything else
then they become yet another
unforeseen problem in that ecosystem
that they have created and that no one
will know what to do with so you know if
if this is just a product yeah and if
and if they could which of course they
can't but if they could you know
grow it in a
contained manner such that it did not
spread its its genetically modified
seed
who knows i don't know if it's in the
germline although plants not having the
sequestered germline probably it will be
right
um
into outside areas if they if they could
basically plant these and and have them
not interact in any way with any native
species
it's going to be i can't imagine they
possibly would and then they're hoping
that it's pulling up heavy metals from
what then
right so they're going to rope like
it every step you take it falls apart
because they both want it to be
part of the ecosystem so that it's
helping you know mitigate heavy metal
toxicity in soils etc
but also they want to then immediately
you know chop those down and use them in
building materials even though it's
going to be soft wood because it grew so
fast but they don't want that returning
to the to the soil because of the heavy
metals that they were supposedly solving
the problem of i mean it's not that they
haven't identified some real problems
but it's like every analysis stops at
exactly the point like we are told the
analysis stops at exactly the point that
it comes to the conclusion they want and
this is you know this is the game the
cdc plays right the cdc is like oh we
got 19 months worth of data we're going
to show you two weeks right here in a
particular state and that's going to
that's going to reveal the pattern we
like right and you know they're just
this is what is happening everywhere
pick and choose the little slice of data
that you like don't actually share the
data but be assured here's a nice graph
with you know maybe even mucked up axes
and trust us we're the science
so
it is the mental disorder called sales
that's what's happening right the mental
disorder called sales is one in which
you don't actually care that your
customer is better off
the important thing you have succeeded
at the point that your customer believes
they will be better off enough that they
buy the thing and what i would argue is
that
we have been running the stupidest gain
of function experiment with respect to
sales in the history of the universe
right we by virtue of the fact that we
have plugged science into the market
right where we have basically said oh
your science is good here convince a
bunch of your peers that your science is
really important so that you win the
funding game right what we do is we
train people who we are supposed to be
we are supposed to be training them to
be totally deaf to whether or not their
conclusions are good for them
right we want you to put forward a
hypothesis because it needs to be
advanced and then to falsify it and to
feel happy that you shot down your own
hypothesis that's what a good scientist
does right instead what we do is we
train scientists who may have gone into
it with that instinct we train them
to be sales people and to lie to each
other right and then we
group them into little clicks where the
point is hell i've got a little lie that
i'm going to include in my grant
proposal and then you can pick up that
lie in your grant proposal and will each
you know validate these lies and the
point is how do you get to a place
where the entire scientific apparatus
all
lies in unison in perfect harmony about
the same topic well this is how you do
it well i mean it's and it's even worse
like but wait there's more
right that you know we know and again
deutsch talks about this in his piece
and gold acre talks about in bad pharma
and it's you know it's well it's well
understood that
pharmaceutical companies write papers
that come to conclusions that are
favorable to them whether or not they're
freaking true or not and then they get
people
who are assessed on the basis of how
many publications they have
to put their names on those papers and
those people whose names are on papers
they did not write whose data they have
not seen that they cannot vouch for then
get all the spoils of academia they get
the they get more grant money and they
get more advancement within their
university and they get the accolades
and then they get more papers coming to
them that they did not write and cannot
vouch for and probably are not true onto
which they just slapped their name and
so it continues right and it is
effectively the pharmaceutical companies
having invaded academia virus-like and
then suddenly people who look like
scientists are spouting pharma [ __ ]
right they're partially spouting science
they're using the you know the
terminology that they were taught to
wield but they are saying things that
are pharma favorable because it it pays
their [ __ ] rent right right they are
effectively infected cells inside of
academia and the problem is the public
has no idea that this has taken place
they've got the elbow patches so it
looks like self
exactly it looks it looks enough like
itself that people buy it and when they
say hey be terrified this terrifying
thing is out there right and you know
what here's the good news the terrifying
thing is coming to get you but it just
so happens that we have the thing that
protects you from the terrifying things
so you're welcome yeah you don't need to
be afraid anymore we did have to skimp a
little bit on the safety but it's for
your own good yep and then and then the
craziest part is you've got
what turns out to be a relatively small
number of people
who are so committed to the science
thing that they will continue to do it
in the face of this sales game yeah and
what has happened to all of us frankly
is we have been demonized and
marginalized and portrayed as crazy and
weird or corrupt or something it's the
exact inverse of the truth
[Music]